hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be ranking my favorite
Harry Potter movies from best to worst I
think one point of Distinction that
needs to be made right away is that
these are not reflective of my book
rankings over the course of a decade the
Beloved book series was adapted into
eight spellbinding films captivating
audiences worldwide and bringing the
Wizarding World to life on on the big
screen however in the process of
adapting the complex and intricate world
of the books into a more visually driven
medium many aspects of the books were
omitted because the films are a less
complete package and because of
filmmakers decisions to prioritize
certain scenes over others they make for
quite a different experience each
possessing their own unique charms and
quirks the best way to describe the
films would be a diluted version of the
books however with that said I'm still
still a huge fan of the Harry Potter
films yes all of them and I have many
positive comments about the way that
each film was constructed as we dive
into this cinematic realm we'll explore
the highs and lows of each movie taking
into account the storytelling visual
effects and the ways in which they
either stayed true to or deviated from
the original Source material I'll try my
best to rationalize why I ranked them
the way that I did but forgive me if in
some instances I'm unable to articulate
myself properly and limited to
explaining things with just a feeling I
know that a lot of you are going to
deviate from my choices here so before
we get started be sure to comment your
best to worst in the comment section
down below let's dive in philosopher
stone my first choice for this list is
the philosopher stone which
coincidentally was also the first
installment in the Harry Potter film
franchise my reasons for this being my
favorite are pure straightforward and
unadulterated the firston reason this
film is my favorite is because it served
as the introduction to The Wizarding
World on screen this film set the stage
for everything else that followed and I
think that with no blueprint to follow
filmmakers did an excellent job of
bringing the Wizarding World to life
when I saw this film on screen for the
first time I really felt the magic the
music the set design the costumes it all
felt so real and I just remember being
in total awe of what I was witnessing
the next reason is nostalgia this film
came out just shy of my 9th birthday
which meant that the students of
Hogwarts were within just a few years of
my own age every time I watch the
philosopher stone I feel like I'm
transported back in time enjoying the
film as my 9-year-old self one other
consideration is that this film stays
relatively faithful to the source
material offering a delightful
adaptation of the first book that sets
the stage for the Epic story to unfold
these may not be the best reasons or
most rational reasons for ranking this
film above the others but for me they're
good enough notable cons include pacing
which was a little slow and acting which
fell a little short due to the actors
being so young however I don't feel that
either of these detract too heavily
prisoner of aaban next up on the list we
have prisoner of aaban the third
installment of the Harry Potter film
franchise released in
2004 5 years after its book counterpart
was released the film was the second
highest grossing film of 2004 but
interestingly it was the second lowest
grossing Harry Potter film overall a
figure that is certainly not indicative
of how good this film actually was this
film differentiated itself from the
previous two largely through the
introduction of an entirely new director
Alfonso quaron while Christopher
Columbus who directed the first two did
an excellent job I think that him taking
a step back for the third installment
was a smart decision as it allowed the
film series to adapt to a new style and
grow into darker
undertones Columbus was the perfect
choice for delivering the more innocent
undertones of the first two films but
quaron was able to take it in a New
Direction introducing a new and unique
visual style establishing an atmosphere
that meshed perfectly with the third
film's overall feel the more mature tone
of this film served as a perfect
reflection of the growth that main
characters had undergone this film also
introduces a ton of new fan favorite
characters like RIS Lupin and Sirus
Black and does a good job of placing an
emphasis on developing character
relationships notable cons include the
way that time travel was handled as well
as deviations from the book order of the
Phoenix up next we have Order of the
Phoenix the fifth installment of the
Harry Potter film series released in
2007 in order of the Phoenix the Harry
Potter film franchise found itself yet
another new director in David the a a
well respected director that ended up
working on the final four films of the
series this film which was visually
stunning and emotionally charged did a
great job at balancing the darker more
mature themes of the story with the
familiar charm and wonder of the magical
world furthermore despite omitting
various elements from the book order of
the Phoenix actually felt quite complete
I'm probably going to get attacked for
that successfully stringing together
various story segments into one
something about this film made it feel
much longer than the others in a good
way among my favorite aspects include
the battle of the Department of
mysteries which was visually stunning
the formation of Dumbledore's Army the
jewel in the ministry Atrium between
Voldemort and Dumbledore and who could
forget Dolores Umbridge love her or hate
her probably hate her UMD was a huge
part of this film and the way that her
character was portrayed was phenomenal
if there's one thing this film excelled
in it was its ability to incite strong
emotion in the viewer from hatred for
umage to Des spare for Harry following
the loss of Sirius this film nailed it
the film loses points for emitting book
content like the entire fifth year
quidditch season Sirus blacks two-way
mirror a scene with Harry and Dumbledore
towards the end of the book and honestly
a fair bit of other stuff Half Blood
Prince o I know I'm going to take some
heat for this one but hear me out Harry
Potter and the Half Blood Prince was the
sixth installment in the Harry Potter
film franchise and was released in 2009
from from what I've seen this film did
not go over well with fans with one of
the biggest reasons for this being that
it didn't stay true to the source
material it deviated from the book
substantially and removed important
memories and sub plants however this is
a list of films that I enjoyed the most
not a list of movies that stayed closest
to the source material that's just one
consideration for me for this reason
half bloodprint still maintains a
reasonably High position on my list I
mentioned earlier that I enjoyed
prisoner of aaban because it Dove right
into the darker side of the Wizarding
World and I think that Half Blood Prince
did something similar taking it one or
even two steps further Half Blood Prince
felt Sinister and uncomfortable as
though something horrible was about to
happen and I happen to really enjoy that
aspect of the film in the film we got
heartbreak in the form of Alvis
Dumbledore's death betrayal or apparent
betrayal in the form of snap's change of
allegiances and a touch of humor in
potions professor a horor slug horn we
also got to closely monitor Malfoy's
Plunge Into Darkness as he transitions
from a petulent but otherwise harmless
young bully to an emotionally disturbed
young man carrying a heavy burden
another Plus for me was being able to
dive a little deeper into Voldemort's
past although I wish that this could
have been explored further Chamber of
Secrets next up we're going all the way
back to 2002 and the release of the
second installment in the series Harry
Potter and the Chamber of of Secrets the
first thing that Chamber of Secrets does
well is provide a seamless followup from
the first installment in the series it
gives us a good sense of continuity and
effectively reintroduces a lot of the
same characters places and Concepts
cementing these ideas in our minds the
film also has a great element of mystery
and Adventure primarily revolving around
a hidden Chamber of Secrets and a giant
bass Lisk Within These elements kept us
engaged and intrigued as Harry Ron and
herione worked together to unravel the
truth it also introduces a plethora of
new characters like the insufferable
gilderoy Lockhart the much beloved Dobby
and the Sinister young Tom Riddle
through the introduction of this wide
range of characters I found myself
experiencing a wide array of emotions
from Fear to anger to excitement as well
as everything in between this film does
quite a good job at staying true to the
original Source material preserving most
core elements brought over from the
books cons include a rather lengthy
runtime and a bit of a lack of character
development which is corrected in the
next film Deathly Hallows part two up
next we have the final installment in
the Harry Potter franchise Deathly
Hallows part two which was released in
2011 this final film which is r with the
motion ends the film franchise well by
providing us with closure and wrapping
up pretty much everything that had
previously been left unanswered unveiled
in this film is Snape's Redemption
Neville's heroism and the resolution of
the Romantic relationships between Ron
and amione as well as Harry and jinny it
also concludes the epic battle between
Harry Potter and Lord Voldemort which
ultimately determines the fade of The
Wizarding World the film also Bears a
significant emotional weight as it deals
with the deaths of beloved characters
and the end of an era for both the
characters and well us the audience
however I think that it carries this
weight well and does a good job at
closing out the story cons include
pacing thing with the film feeling a bit
rushed at times despite being split into
two parts and the epilog which somehow
didn't feel quite sufficient as a final
scene following eight amazing films
deathly Hall's part one up next we have
the penultimate installment of the Harry
Potter franchise deathly hallers part 1
which was released in 2010 in my view
the main difference between deathly
hallers part 1 and two is that two is
action driven focusing on resolution and
one is character driven focusing on the
last bits of character development
before the story is concluded I can't
really even begin to dive into deathly H
is part one without first discussing one
of my favorite aspects of the story The
Tale of the Three Brothers the story
which is uniquely animated and narrated
by himani Granger gives me chills every
time I watch the film in fact this scene
alone bumped the entire film up a point
for me saving this film from the last
spot on the list that's how much I
enjoyed this singular component of the
story as for the rest of the film it was
just a bit too slow goinging for me and
it didn't seem to evoke the same magic
that I felt watching the other films
this film made me feel Bleak and
hopeless in a bit of a mundane sort of
way which is probably what it was
intended to make me feel but it also
kind of suffers in that it only really
serves as the buildup film for the final
film when we finally get resolution it
was just a part one which unlike the
other films in the series made it feel a
little bit
incomplete the film did provide a little
bit more of an intimate glimpse into the
Dynamics of Harry Ron and Herman's
relationships which I enjoyed but I
think that there may have been a bit too
much of that at the end of the day this
was still a Harry Potter film and I
still enjoyed it very much however
pitted up against the tough competition
of the other films this one didn't quite
hit the mark in the perfect world I
think they should have removed some of
part one added in a little bit of part
two then developed part two further
Goblet of Fire last up on the list we
have Goblet of Fire the fourth
installment of the Harry Potter film
franchise released in
2015 I didn't originally have Goblet of
Fire in the last position in fact when I
was first organizing this list goblet of
fire started up quite high but the
longer I wrote about each film The More
I realized that despite Goblet of Fire's
success in a multitude of areas it
simply entertained me the least Goblet
of Fire was uniquely directed by Mike
Newell who having never read the Harry
Potter books himself didn't really hit
the mark you'd think that after getting
the job he could have made the effort to
read the books but after watching the
film for the first time it was apparent
that he hadn't at give or take 734 Pages
depending on the version you get Goble
of fire had a lot of information to
cover and it felt like Neil was a bit
too Reckless when it came to deciding
what would and wouldn't be featured in
the film Pros include the try WI a
tournament the inclusion of other
Wizarding schools and the return of
Voldemort cons include an apparent lack
of character development particularly
with characters like Barty Crouch Jr and
what I would describe as disregard for
the source material apparently new based
his version of Hogwarts on his old
boarding school which probably wasn't a
good thing to implement in the fourth
installment of an existing and
successful film franchise pacing in the
film is a bit weird with some scenes
feeling rushed and underdeveloped and
others such as the Ule ball feel over
long overall the film struggles to
balance the various subplots and themes
resulting in a disjointed narrative that
left me feeling a bit
dissatisfied like I said earlier this is
still a Harry Potter film and it still
gets top marks when compared with other
films out there it just doesn't quite
stand up to the competition when
compared with other Harry Potter films
and that's it for my list what do you
think how does my list compared to yours
I'd love to see how you guys rank the
films so if you haven't already be sure
to comment your list down below also if
you have compelling Arguments for why my
list should be rearranged then comment
that as well if you enjoy the content
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live